this is
new year new year's eve uh
so you talked about secession and the
world burning down and
you holding the match at the end
yes standing with a big smile on your
face yes
why so serious but uh let me ask you
if it doesn't include flame and
secession and destruction
and a laughing malice and makeup and a
white suit at the end
uh how do we bring more kindness and
love to the world in 2021
oh easy be comfortable
saying i want to be happy and if there's
someone
who interjects and gives you attitude
arms length them surround yourself with
people who also
want to be happy here's a great example
my buddy chris williamson who i
mentioned before he's a podcaster does
modern wisdom
he's he's an awesome dude and we became
friend very close friends this past year
and he was in dubai recently and he sent
me pics from dubai by the pool
just loving life and it took me a week
and then it clicked in my head and i'm
like you know what
for some other people if they saw him
underwear model
at the pool they would think this is him
bragging or humble bragging
and that never entered my head i'm like
oh man i'm so glad my boy
can be having a good time and is sharing
his joy
with me that's the kind of people you
need to surround yourself with
where it never enters their head to be
resentful
or anything other than sharing in
your bounty what makes you happy
i'm happy all the time and one of the
points i made
in my life is like i really hated i
really did not like to give advice
because i feel don't give advice until
you know you're talking about
and to me what makes me happy is being
self-actualized
i am in a position with my career where
i could be myself 24 7
where i never have to engage in small
talk where i never have to interact with
someone i don't want to
and i'm very blessed to have that very
few people have that
and to have that be not only um
to have that be like rewarded and having
people
find that something of value to them
makes me
very very happy but also being an uncle
you know i have two little nephews there
they make me very very happy
um sure my sister's raising them
russians so they talk like immigrants
but
that's okay we're gonna change that um
we have to dismember her that's fine
that makes me happy and like to be able
to
to be able to finish this book and know
it's going to give people a sense of
hope
that's really validating uh
what are you most grateful for for our
conversation today
you're stealing my debt what am i most
grateful for
i am very grateful
that i can come in here not knowing what
we're going to talk about
and no it's not going to be something i
have to be on guard about
or i have to watch my words and that
neither you or your audience is going to
be responding derisively
i feel safe here you're welcome
thanks for talking michael it was
awesome
you